あっつ入った山なきゃかわいいリップが来てますねどうした話聞こうか聞きますか僕が
木型話きますか
a 私は済みシャツを本日2月17日
車で運転したら使われましたを見て俺の運転免許なんですけどゴールド免許なんだよ
なんだけ無事故無違反を5年くらいかなそれくらいでやってようやくなるということで
有料っていう
ゴールド免許証っていうんだったんですけどはず2冊を本日
スピード違反により逮捕されましたも逮捕っていうのが最後ではないな
違反ですね逮捕じゃないですよね交通
大洪水版でございますねああ
福田5年間無事故無違反だったんですよね
3捕まるような
ここが合ってないわけでもないですけど家の前家の前でです警察が何人かいて本どっち
家の愛の小さい径でこっちは何て言ったら10キロちょいオーバーしてああ
スピード違反ですって感じで捕まりましたもう
いや5年が無事故無違反でようやくゴールドウィングになれたんですけど取り消し
だろうなり反省と取り消しでしょ
1点減点されるって言ってたで何か本当はこう提案するとね
ストってね出頭しなきゃいけないんですよ出頭いやもうそんなまあ常識的なスピードな
んではあるんですけど
道によってはですね大低速度というのは決まってていいと
杉田僕がつもりです全部俺行くよな小道分どうぞそうだね守り場所スピードは本当にや
心が緩んでました
ちょっとの運転に慣れて緩む時ぐらいにコッパシーンでこうやってされた方が何だか気
がし記事丸んでやーもう
8日よかったじゃないね見れば罰則金まーすぎ一番2000円これ新潟の20個前に
らはないと出頭してくださいと言われました本当に行ってきますスピード超過した僕が
悪いのでもこれってメダル仏教ですけどちょっとあの
[音楽]
ん
質問コーナーします
この動画でコメント欄に僕に対する質問 d クエスト何でも思ったことを文句言って
ほしいことをやってほしいこと素朴な疑問質問なんでも書いてください今回はちょっと
久々にねちょっとスタンダードな質問コーナー久々にやろうと思ってるんでもういつも
通りの完全なんでもコメントしてくださいも動画で使われます
今月の真面目系てるちょっとほんと面白に振るかなちょっとコメントを見てみないと
わかんないんですけど1月中が2月中まで募集しておりますでさあうー駄文
3月にできればの質問コーナー出そうと思いますああああもうちょっとあー今日はティ
が悪い
まっ違う歩いスピード超過したオレが悪い
っとまぁしか本当に反省しておりますただ
持っただなあんな椎体道カーそっかぁ
それでねでねこれが捕まった後ですね後ろの人も捕まっててなんかもうすごい網で後年
が海でこう魚捕まえてるみたいな感じですよねそういうやっぱり気が緩んでいる所で
しっかりとダメですよというのを伝えていくことによって法2事故が減るのかなと思い
ますその一人でございます
つばのどういうテンションもべきを
動画まあん
ザックさんコメントしてくださいとが俺の免許そんな彼を生かしたにもうショップです
けど前向きに考えましょう交通事故にならなくてよかった
ちょっとまたあの運転対する意識してしまったので引き続き地をつけようと思います
ちょっと春のスペシャル質問コーナーしようと思っていると気合入ってますよちょっと
エンジン経てことを探求ぞスピード違反でスタン次は緩めてやっていこうかな
さーああこんな別に何か動画にしなくてもいいことなんですけども中谷詰まったこと
ですこれを見てまたみんなはなくさん気をつけるようにあったらいいなと思ったんで
ちょっとで自分から暴露していくスタイルですそう
ぜいぜい初スピード超過やちょっと恐々本当に
12,000円でしょうアイドル皆さんの質問をお待ちしておりますまずコメント欄で
センスある人ほんとすごいですから良いコメントは俺が全部ば釣り飛びますので是非
コメント下さい今日はもうふて寝します
[音楽]
ブーブー
ぱっちょ